les dominos tombent les uns après les
autres sous l'effet de la pandémie
ducobu 19 partout dans le monde et donc
en france également la crise sanitaire a
pris une tournure économique et social
on entre là dans un moment compliqué les
semaines qui viennent et même l'automne
seront très difficiles
socialement ce sera même très dur malgré
un plan de relance économique de 100
milliards d'euros dont les entreprises
sont les grandes bénéficiaires
la liste des plans sociaux s'allonger
aucun secteur n'est épargné dans la
grande distribution 1475 postes sont
menacés chez auchan
les laboratoires boiron annonce la
suppression de 6 146 emplois sur un
total de 2600 dans les télécoms 1233
salariés de nokia devrait se retrouver
sur le carreau en 2021 à nextradiotv la
maison-mère des médias bfm tv rmc
annonce la suppression de 245 postes en
cdi et une réduction de 33 % du volume
des intérimaires on va faire le maximum
pour sauver tout le monde
je ne dis pas que l'on aura des
résultats qui nous permettront d'éviter
toutes les faillites alors parlons-en
des résultats le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est qu'il laisse à désirer la
dernière annonce de plan social en date
c'est celle de bridgestone le fabricant
japonais de pneumatiques vient
d'annoncer la fermeture de son site à
béthune dans le pas de calais 8 163
emplois sont menacés
une décision qui a révolté le ministre
de l'économie
bridgestone a pris une décision
révoltante avec des méthodes révoltante
et des conséquences révoltante
le ministre a délégué aux transports se
veut de son côté plus menaçant
bridgestone aura à rendre des comptes
c'est un acte qui manque singulièrement
de forme parce que quand vous prenez des
mesures aussi radicales pour plus 800
salariés pour plus de 200 intérimaires
vous allez à minima leur annoncer et le
préparer
destructions d'emplois et des faillites
en cascade 715 milles emplois ont été
détruits au premier semestre sous
l'effet de la crise sanitaire et le taux
de chômage pourrait atteindre 9 5% à la
fin de l'année pourtant le pire reste à
venir pourquoi parce que les mesures
d'urgence mises en place par l'exécutif
ne sont pas éternelles sens sera donc
bientôt terminée du prêt garanti par
l'état du report de charge des aides
sectorielles et du dispositif de chômage
partiel
que ce soit du côté des faillites des
plans sociaux ou de l'emploi la crise a
jusqu'ici produit des effets de second
ordre au regard du potentiel de
destruction de capacité que suppose le
niveau actuel d'activité
cette tempête économique pourrait
laisser place à un univers social chaud
bouillant ce handicap et j les jeunes
ont d'ailleurs déjà repris le chemin des
manifestations en dépit des
interdictions prononcées dans le cadre
de la crise sanitaire